[Music]
good morning hello nice School dear
birthday boy
that shirt that's funny it also makes me
feel bad love you Dad
it's not always been there
that thing will tell you your life's
potential
where'd you get it no idea it just
appeared like magic
you know what I got Superstar well I got
dancer male model Mickey stop what's
going on why is everybody trying to
change their lives overnight we're
getting a divorce the Morpho inspired us
what was your card healer a signed to
engage in self-healing or maybe a Mad
Doctor Is In the profession that you do
every day
you asked if I was happy are you happy
I'm 40 years old I have no discernible
Talent apart from whistling and I've
only ever been in one relationship I
don't know if I'm happy you never had to
think about it which was nice actually
it's not like I really believe there's a
magical machine that can tell people
what they're capable of
but literally everyone is trying it so
they got together a week ago and now
they're married that's fun
maybe everything is not quite as it
seems that is deep I think I have
everything I ever wanted maybe you
didn't want enough this machine it's
magic or not it's reminding people
our lives have more than one possible
path
[Music]
we have been asking where the morph will
come from what's inside
what we should be asking is what's
inside of us
you're going to decide your own life
potential
gonna be
[Applause]